الى الملف النووي الايراني حيث قال البيت
الابيض في بيان ان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جاك سولف بحث بقلق كبير التقدم
الذي احرزته ايران ببرنامجها نووي مع
نظيره الاسرائيلي ساحي ووزير الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه رون ديرمن
ووفدين يمثلان وكالات البلدين الامنيه
والدفاعيه والاستخباراتيه واضاف البيان ان
المشاركين في الاجتماع الذي عقد في البيت
الابيض تعهدوا بتعزيز التنسيق الخاص بمنع
ايران من حيازه السلاح النووي وزياده ردع
انشطتها الاقليميه العدائيه كما استعرض
المناورات المشتركه الاخيره بين الجيشين
الامريكي والاسرائيلي وقال البيان انه تم
ايضا بحث الجهود المبذوله لتعزيز اندماج
اسرائيل الامني والسياسي في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط من خلال اتفاقيات ابرام ومنتدى
النقب واضاف البيان ان مستشار الامن
القومي من جديد التزاما الرئيسين بايدن او
الرئيس بايدن بامن اسرائيل